welcome back to the iced coffee hour i'm
shelby church and so far the podcast has
made
two hundred and fifty thousand that's
actually a really good very close uh
199. yeah was it one nine nine zero nine
eight yeah we were trying to throw you
off okay had you said two you had been
the closest so far of anybody ever
really off by one thousand i was almost
cheating because i watched an episode or
i listened to one in the car
not long ago so i knew it would be
around that range
great guess which episode you watch i
don't remember because i'll like click
on them if i'm on like a road trip kind
of thing okay um
[Music]
i don't know let me see
like i swear i didn't be like ass not
it was my last episode
just make it small
oh i listened to the tech lead one oh oh
i was like man the drama
yeah yes interesting i don't know if we
get right into the juicy drama with with
tech lead right now or maybe you should
introduce yourself for a second how
about you introduce yourself and then
we'll talk about what happened with tech
lead we'll keep everyone on the toes
okay well i'm shelby church i'm a
youtuber
i make all kinds of videos don't really
ever stick to any specific niche so
everything from like sometimes real
estate stuff i have an airbnb in palm
springs so videos about home renovations
um travel
all that but yeah i do youtube and have
an airbnb and also you two have had a
long lasting relationship of you
reacting to her videos and starting some
drama because he would
so you had a gripe with graham because
graham would make something oh yeah no
you make more of my videos than i make
on me i know i feel terrible i do you so
bad do you feel i don't know about that
great because i've linked shel first of
all shelby's name your name i'm talking
like you're not here your name is in
every single one of my titles your uh
every single time like go and subscribe
to sheldon church the link is in the
description it's at the very top every
single time i do feel bad
because yeah it's really a youtube thing
it's not like you're somehow able to
like choose that
but it's just crazy because i'm like oh
i put so much work into it but i know
and that's one of the things when i
watch your videos every single time i
compliment them because i'm like the
amount of b-roll that you do in for
every video
is mind-blowing of just how much
planning goes into these videos and how
much research you did like i loved the
the 3d printed home tour video you did
that was a great video it was really
good we should react to it we should be
active
they wouldn't tell me how much that cost
though and i really wanted to know i
think it'd be a lot yeah i think so
because they were building it not as
like this is what you could have really
it was more of like a showcase of like
this is the nicest one they got a really
good architect in texas to make it so
they're trying to make it like almost
like their model s
you know and then they'll have model
threes that they'll like roll out so
that makes sense you toured a 3d printed
house so they actually had like this
weird crane looking thing that could
like lay whatever material
yeah it looked like toothpaste and it
created an actual house yeah it's a mix
of concrete and something else so they
call it lava creek
and they're making
like
i forget what they even call it it's
like a martian habitat thing at a nasa
center they're doing all kinds of stuff
like not just houses it's crazy and do
you think that there's actually
sustainability in that or there's like
longevity in that will that keep going
i think so because they're already
building a hundred like a community of
100 of them in austin because it saves
time like the labor of like building the
walls and stuff but i guess it's a
little misleading because people think
like oh you 3d print the whole house but
you can't 3d print like plumbing you
can't 3d print like doing electrical
work like there's so much you still have
to do
like you can't 3d print anything about a
kitchen you know
but it saves
some labor in time and then maybe they
can figure out the other stuff later
but i don't know i think it's cool i
think it's a step in making home home
building automated which i think is so
interesting like prefab houses all that
stuff i love researching the prefabs are
i don't like them though because they're
a lot very boxy very square with this
one you could do like you know yeah it
was corners
very neat but i have a feeling it's so
expensive for them because this is like
brand new and it's like here's what we
could do and it's more like a showcase
they say that it's 10 to 30 percent
cheaper but it's like i don't know that
for sure
because i don't have the numbers yeah
but how long does it take you to plan
out a video like that that one didn't
take that long i just found the house
emailed them like talked to actually a
subscriber messaged me about it they're
like you should check this out because i
think they knew i was going to be in
austin for south by southwest
um
and so it's like a bit of time
coordinating okay when can i go check it
out i shot there for maybe two hours not
that long ideally i would longer but it
was kind of busy because it was south by
southwest so they like had stuff to do
so i was like get as much as i could in
that time
and then i
took a long time to edit it actually
because i have a new camera that it just
requires more steps to stabilize all the
footage
and i don't know color correct it i shot
on two different cameras so like trying
to make them look similar because one it
shoots very flat and cinematic and then
the sony one i have shoots just more i
guess digital looking
so
i don't know it's probably like a day
and a half or two days to edit maybe
more it's a while yeah
geez how long does it take you to edit
one of your videos graham uh four hours
usually four to five hours yeah yeah i
would love to speak up i want to find an
editor but i've
realized it needs to be like
a really like a producer like
collaborator because there's so much
voice over and all that like
i don't think i can send it away there's
so much footage first of all it'll be
like 50 gigabytes of footage if i were
to upload that and send it to someone
that would just take like two days to
even send
so i gotta find someone just
in seattle or something you gotta do
what we do alex set up a server i've
never seen this before you upload direct
to like i could upload from my computer
it goes directly to alex's computer and
normally i was uploading dropbox the
thing would take like one to two hours
for this i upload the entire video so
more footage and it's like 20 minutes
and can you get on it when you're like
in a different state
yeah or is it yep yeah the the biggest
uh limiter is your internet speed but if
you live in a newer type house every you
know people are having fiber in in the
houses now and so
yeah if you if you have fiber in both
locations it could be super fast yo wait
a second you you left california right
wow okay i think we uh we got the title
here why shelby church left california
what she hates about california
when did you leave when was this i left
in october because my lease was up and i
toured a bunch of places and i just
didn't really like any of them
because everything was kind of taken at
that time it was like a weird time it
still is i think kind of trying to find
a place to rent so i would go tour
places and they'd be like we have one
unit left in this whole building and it
would be on the bottom floor terrible
lighting like it would be fine if you
didn't do youtube but i was just like
this just isn't gonna work
and the prices were also a lot more than
they used to be i just wasn't excited
about it i was like maybe i should just
put myself in storage and go try
somewhere else because i lived in la for
eight years
um so that's what i ended up doing i
went to new york for a month and then
i've kind of bounced around i did
another month in l.a because it was i
mean in february it's kind of cold most
places and i think it's helpful if
you're making videos to be somewhere
that's sunny like i shoot a lot of stuff
outside and i just prefer it personally
like i just like nice weather
um so i left and now i just got a place
in seattle because it's going to be
nicer in the summer
but i've even considered like still
having a place in california in the
winter maybe would be nice yeah because
i still like california like there are
things i definitely don't like about it
especially when i went to new york for a
month i was like
whoa la there are a lot of things that
i don't like
that i just didn't even think about like
what mostly traffic and how it's not
walkable like you have to drive
everywhere
and i just realized i hate driving kind
of like actually it just it makes me
feel like drained and tired and i'm
running the tesla which drives drives
for you okay what i realized though is i
need
my windows tinted because it's like the
sun beating down on you
um
but yeah i don't know something about it
i just don't like it i even i like
taking the subway and stuff i know some
people really don't like it but i was
like this is amazing after being
somewhere where you have to drive and
park and all that it was nice to be able
to walk and just like hop on and like do
stuff on your phone
yeah
yeah did taxes play a role in that or no
um
it did in my final decision of where to
live because i did want to live in new
york but it's even higher of taxes than
la and the rent is higher and everything
and i really just looked at like where
do i want to be in five years like i
don't really want to build a life in new
york i think it's worth it if you want
to live there forever like
then yeah might as well do it but i
would probably live there for like two
years have fun
and then go either to california or
seattle or wherever
and
it's just a huge cost to do that when i
could probably
like i like new york but i think i would
get sick of it especially in the winter
um and yeah you pay i think it's like 14
total taxes state taxes there i thought
california was yeah california is there
some sort of like city tax there as well
yeah so it ends up being a lot and the
rent is just even more than yeah
california and what's the state tax in
seattle
none really yeah there's none in
washington yeah you know what actually
we're gonna be going to seattle we'll
have to talk about this probably in the
next like two weeks
day trip oh yeah day trip yeah what's it
for again just for a tesla thing oh yeah
oh wait what's the tesla thing i i got a
tesla roadster
but like the original one yes i'm
picking i'm not picking it up but i'm
meeting the guy in seattle washington
we're gonna do a podcast with him oh
that's cool yeah yeah so his name is
carl medlock and he's known as the tesla
whisperer because he keeps all of the
original roadsters alive that's like
this guy he has he he owns i think
multiple tesla roadsters so i bought one
of his i've seen one once an original
one and i saw it like plugged in and
everything but it just looked like it
was charging a lot slower but that would
be cool to have yeah so just imagine
like you've you you make the tesla model
3 content and that blows up
what's a roadster going to do it's
either going to bomb or it's going to do
really well yeah so i mean excited to
see definitely when the new roadsters
come out like that's yeah that's
insanely well whenever that does in the
cyber truck yeah
but first let's thank our sponsor titan
graham the market is so volatile right
now every time i think i have a good
investing strategy the market changes if
only i had a crystal ball but you don't
need a crystal ball when you have the
experts at titan who can invest your
money for you but graham isn't active
investment management reserved for the
ultra wealthy not with titan all you
need is 100 to get started titan is the
first investment app that has a team of
experts who actively manage your money
in a way that hasn't been available for
everyday investors before just deposit
your money select your portfolio and
titan's team of analysts will allocate
your money for you and you can get
updates about decisions being made with
your money and you can even ask the team
questions to learn more all within the
app with all the chaos going on in the
market right now trying to invest
yourself could be pretty risky but
titan's team of experts track macro
trends war inflation and commodity
prices on a daily basis and can use that
knowledge to help your money grow so
whether you have your money in
individual stocks or index funds right
now is the perfect time to diversify and
leave it to the experts at titan and
right now if you use the url down below
in the description titan.com ich you can
get your first three months of active
investment management all for free
that's titan.com ich for three months of
zero fees thank you so much titan and
back to the podcast podcast we need more
tesla content from you i mean and more
income paid videos
well i'm gonna have more palm springs
income updates okay like airbnb i like
that video a lot thanks yeah so yeah
you'll have stuff to react to there
good good good good how is the palm
springs place going it's good it's
awesome yeah so we put it live on airbnb
in january
in the first couple days we didn't get
any bookings and i was like should we
lower our price what was your price 700
a night oh my gosh 700 yeah it's like a
lot so my property manager
recommended that because she manages
like a bunch of airbnbs she was like
trust me this is the going rate for this
kind of house so it's like okay
and then it really did fill up like
march ended up being 26 out of 31 nights
booked and april was probably like
20 because i blocked off like a few days
to go myself
and two of those were coachella weekends
and hopefully no one has rented it for
stagecoach but i'm hoping yeah for that
but yeah it's been really awesome
because for so long it just felt like a
money pit that i was like working on and
like there'd just be small headaches all
the time i was like is this gonna be
worth it
and now actually making money from it is
so crazy because you know youtube it's
like passive income kind of but not
really like you really have to be making
videos all the time i think um with this
it's just insane because i get paid for
it and i'm like i didn't even think
about it barely
like i actually didn't really do much
for it because my property manager
handles
most of like dealing with guests and
everything and then she'll let me know
if we need like we had someone come out
and fix some electrical things sure yeah
but that's like
she handles even that she'll just tell
me like okay is it cool if we charge for
this i'm like yeah or i'll order stuff
on amazon someone broke the nest so i
just ordered one how'd they break it
it fell off like they were trying to
reset it and those things they can like
pop off like you can take it off so i
think it like shattered um
but i just like mentally prepared myself
like things are gonna break like little
things like that like it's fine
like that will happen yeah so have you
found it to be really profitable yeah
definitely so our
i guess i forget what i said in the
video the one that was going over march
but that one i think it ended up being
after our property manager after her
fees we made twelve thousand dollars for
that month and then the mortgage and all
the expenses was like four to five
so after that
was like
seven i guess but i feel like it paying
the mortgage and everything is still a
little bit like in my mind that's still
yeah like equity into it
so i was really happy with that i think
april is going to be a bit more because
of coachella yeah so i'm happy with that
with just like i can go for free it's
like yeah i don't really have to put
much time into it what was your all in
on that like the total cost with
renovation because i saw you did a lot
of the renovation like you did a lot of
that yourself and like you were there a
lot right yeah but we hired people to do
like a lot of it we pretty much painted
the ceilings ourselves
and then
like knocked out a wall and then little
things like we put in the doorknobs and
like stuff like that stuff that you
would do in an apartment even
um i forgot like the down payment ended
up being like 250 or something like that
because of the limit like the loan limit
in riverside county at that time
now it's higher
i think it's like 700 000 now but then
it was like 500 000 so we put down more
than 20 which everyone's always like oh
i think it's fine yeah
um and then the renovations i think it
was like 150 000 into renovations
so
maybe a little more than that
but yeah i think that somebody who
is really good with like home
construction could do this whole thing a
lot cheaper
but we definitely did stuff just because
we like want it as a second vacation
type of house too so we're like let's
get this tie i like it we're not gonna
go with the cheapest thing
like you would maybe a flip yep so
yeah it ended up being a lot but
now i'm like it's so nice getting that
passive income yeah so what was the
total cash on that you said how much
down 250 250 plus 150 so you're in it
four
four hundred thousand and you're making
probably what sixty thousand a year net
back like if you averaged
probably so you make it about twelve
cash return on your money plus paying
down the equity plus the appreciation
yeah it negotiated so much
i was like what do you think it's worth
now like 1. 1.2 or 3. yeah
wow yeah and we bought it for 750. gosh
the market's crazy i'm like how is that
even real
ugh i kind of like that because it's
obviously it's cool but it then makes it
harder to buy anything else yeah
palm springs has become really trendy
though with coachella like now people
are catching on to it is like this cool
like vacation spot mm-hmm because you
can go golfing there's like really cool
restaurants there um
there's like a lot of stuff you can do i
think people just like to go have a
house with a pool and like chill relax
grill do that kind of thing needs a
casino there
that's what they need there is really i
haven't been to it but i think my sister
went once
yeah how is that legal
because there's indian land so basically
like every other like plot of land is
indian land
and so
um
some houses are on leased land but ours
is on i really didn't want that so i'm
like what i know you can renegotiate
your lease but like imagine that ends in
30 years what if they're just like no
there's always a possibility like no we
want to put a casino in there yeah yeah
and like just get rid of your house like
that would suck
so i avoided that yeah there's
significant parts of marina del rey
believe it or not that are on land
leases yeah what yeah
who owns it um i think it's the state i
i could be totally wrong but uh they're
all those big high-rise condo buildings
or land leases not all of them but a
significant portion of marina del rey i
didn't know that yeah and so they expire
i think a big chunk of them expiring
like 2050 2040. so they're starting to
negotiate them now just like you got to
get ahead of it you know because imagine
30 years from now it's like well sorry
we really don't want to what do you do
we're going to tear them down
you're out of luck so so yeah yeah i
don't like the idea of least land at all
right
now that's great i'm glad it's going
well do you ever have subscribers stay
there just because it's yours they saw
it online they're like i want to stay
there i don't think so yet i think it's
really just been people on airbnb that
find it because it's
like a significant amount of money like
we do a four night minimum so to stay
there you need to like
be willing to pay
like a couple thousand dollars at least
it accommodates six people though so
it's usually groups going they all split
it and then it's like cheaper than a
hotel there yeah um
so i think it's like it's not that easy
for subscribers to coordinate or like
want to pay that much which is
understandable that would be a good
video though wouldn't it like i've
reviewed shelby church's
if you're gonna stay there anyway yeah
it's like the end it's a write-off
because you're doing it for the video
purposes i know i think that would be
cool but no one so far has
said that like maybe someone did and
they just didn't tell us but i think
it's just it's really been people who
are like oh i go to palm springs every
year
to escape the winter in chicago or
whatever
so i don't think it's subscribers but
who knows yeah i think the best time of
year is like right now like i was just
there before this and it's hot enough
that you want to get in the pool
and you don't even have to heat you
don't have to pay to heat the pool quite
as much as when it's like 60 degrees out
it's so expensive to heat yeah that's
like our biggest expense is heating the
pool
um didn't you say in your video that you
charged the tenants now or it's like a
fee now to eat the pool but we still eat
a lot of the cost like we charge them i
think like 60 a night but it's actually
like 150 a day to heat really yeah but
it's not as much when it's like
back-to-back bookings
because it takes two days to get it up
to that temperature and then you can
kind of leave it there it's not as
expensive those days they're probably
like eighty dollars a day like i looked
on the
socalgas website
um so if you have people booked back to
back
it just it's a little more efficient i
guess than if you had one booking for a
week and then nothing for a week and
then one more
you'd be having to heat it for more than
14 days it'd be more like 16 because you
have to have those two days to get it up
if that makes sense yeah
yeah so
that's the one thing i'm like there are
solar
pool heating stuff but like our pool
equipment is new like i don't want to
buy another one yet yeah yeah but first
we gotta thank our sponsor ftxus ftx is
the most complete crypto and finance app
out there it allows users to buy and
sell nfts and crypto with no fees
whatsoever you might have heard of ftx
through their partnerships with tom
brady steph curry coachella or the miami
heat stadium ftx is one of the largest
crypto exchanges in the world in terms
of daily users and trading volume and
they have a valuation of about eight
billion dollars and their founder sam
bankman freed plans to give away 99
of what he personally makes to charity
you see most exchanges charge two to
three dollar minimum fees on every
transaction but with ftx you can trade
as much as you want all for free they
also make dollar cost averaging easy
with things like recurring buys where
they can pull money directly from your
bank account on a weekly bi-weekly or
monthly basis and invest it for you
automatically they even offer a crypto
friendly debit card allowing you to
spend crypto at millions of merchants
worldwide so start trading crypto and
nfts with no fees today by downloading
the ftx app with the link down below in
the description again the link is down
below in the description that you click
right now like right now just click it
thank you so much ftx for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast
back to the podcast so what are you
investing in now are you looking to buy
more real estate or what are you doing
yeah for a while i was kind of looking
in seattle but
even there i was just like i don't i
don't know i just i really wanted a
place after like traveling for a while i
was like i just need to like get a spot
rather than
wait like and i guess it's just you want
to wait for the right spot place to buy
you know and i'm fine with like renting
for a year but um
i bought a piece of land in joshua tree
and so me and you know rob built
that youtuber
yes he does all the homes there right
yes yeah so we're collaborating on a
build out there like an airbnb that's
cool joshua tree yeah now he does those
communities right because i i subscribed
to him back when we met him on the boat
a while ago and yeah and he does the big
communities
rents out everything
yeah and he has i stayed in his um tiny
house in joshua tree once too and made a
video about it and it was just like
really cool like it's very unique it
does really well on airbnb
um
and it's awesome because he knows
everything really about the area like
contractors in the area who to call to
set up like the percolation test to get
a septic tank installed like all these
things that would be like so much harder
if i was just doing it on my own but i
can more freely go to it like he has a
ton of projects going on and i'm always
going to palm springs so i can just
drive over once construction starts and
like check on it more
that's a great way to make money so i
stayed in yosemite over this last
weekend jack you got to hear this it's
incredible so i went to this uh it's
called auto camp yosemite oh i've heard
of these yeah like a uh airstream yeah
so you drive in this place they have 85
airstreams
that are just set up like back to back
to back to back and in between them they
have these like kind of like modular
homes that are a little bit bigger
but they all rent between like 250 on
the low end like five hundred dollars
airstreams yeah per night so it's a
luxury airstream
in an airstream a renovated one like
that is like 150 000 it's not
like
no i thought less than that yeah it
should be less but i've heard of they
can get up to that if it's like really
tricked out yeah no i mean this the rs
was nice like you walk in and there's
just like a little mini refrigerator a
sink a bathroom on one side a bed on the
other windows all around it and then
behind is like just a few chairs and a
fire pit
and so i'm sitting there wondering how
much money are these people making
and so i i added up i'm like okay
average three something 350 night in the
middle of it all is like this
convenience store it's like a clubhouse
where they have like wi-fi a fire pit a
convenience store an upper level for
stuff
and i calculated that they're probably
pulling in about eight to nine million
dollars a year wow
and then what's their expense it's like
you know cleanings uh there's so there's
someone at the front desk at all times
parking around so i'm guessing they're
probably making about five and a half
million dollars a year
from from this one community of 85
airstreams
and it's not even in yosemite by the way
it says camp yosemite it's 30 minutes
outside of yosemite and the place was
booked like every single one of them was
taken they had nothing that makes me
think it's like what if i just bought a
house with rv parking got a cheap
trailer and rented it for like 100 or
something 450 bucks a night yeah
i mean depending on
your land and zoning
but i mean the the area that they
developed
was specific for this so they took a big
plot of land they tiered it so they they
kind of leveled off certain areas and
then in the middle of it all was like
this big it was man-made uh man-made
lake in the middle of it all whoa that's
so cool fish in it and like you could go
fishing there if you wanted to
that's crazy i'm thinking like oh my how
amazing would that be and it probably
i'm guessing this probably would have
cost them like
i'm going to say 10 to 13 million to
build this like from start to finish so
you make your money back within about
two years three years
graham was so excited about this because
i know because he texted me yeah he's
like by the way alex uh how much should
we pay for the uh
the airstream and i texted him back and
then like literally five minutes later
he's like so i've calculated that uh i'm
they're making about this much i'm like
that's how you know graham like i knew
his eyes lit up yeah
i loved it i absolutely loved this idea
that's i love the idea too i love the
like the idea of airbnb airbnb is so
easy it is so easy and i want to keep
doing it but i just hate having people
yeah now what's interesting though is uh
uh yosemite has so many regulations
about airbnb and they're very strict
about airbnb so it makes sense that this
is this is like 30 minutes outside it's
uh maria posa county it's right by
oakhurst so they don't have the stricter
regulation las vegas has very strict
regulations in airbnb yeah takes away
from the hotels so if you could find
like a cool community somewhere around
here like i would love that what a
business what about when we went to that
pokemon event like
but i i bet their airbnb those um
airstreams out they are it didn't
i
i didn't like it i didn't like it seemed
kind of cheap to me i think it was the
airstream like how it was done yeah we
saw because there's a little community
here in vegas but it was in a really
not good part of town kind of like
downtown las vegas they had maybe 15 of
them
uh surrounding like this pool that
looked like it was from the 60s
i'm not a fan of it but this place in
yosemite like it's cool yeah bio70 was
incredible like i and i always loved
getting home i would have stayed there
an extra week like i loved it and i
never really yeah i loved it jack if
you're looking for a place to go
seriously for like a week why did you
like it so much it was nice it was just
like you they're fresh
uh
no not really i just do like thumbnails
and stuff like that now but i wanted to
you wanted to work more yeah i mean i
had a great time not working but yeah
but it was so just like nice and uh just
like
the airstream it was really i'm happy
for you it got me motivated i think it's
good like i bet the air that you were
breathing over there was like so fast
it just rained yeah would you ever get
an airstream yes
yeah that's what he wants to do that's
his dream is to like travel yeah across
the united states yeah trailer stream
yeah airstreams are interesting because
you there's one kind i think that you
can drive but usually you have to tow it
but if you set it up somewhere it can do
so well in airbnb but joshua trees like
crack down on stuff like that
because they're not permitted structures
so those tents those like glamping yeah
a lot of the um airstreams have been
shut down there but a lot of places you
can still do that so stupid not a
permitted structure it's a tent
it's like yeah i don't know why they do
yeah i don't really know so that would
do well too i think the glamping is
gonna
only be more popular it's gonna be
really trendy like because i because i
saw that too uh the big huge teepees and
they had like two beds set up with a
heater and like it was really nice i've
stayed in a camping thing once and it
was fun
yeah like i would do it again so i don't
know why they're cracking down on a good
thing that's interesting you know you
got me thinking i want to buy a plot of
land here i wanted to do that and just
like and just like throw some trailers
on it airstream's sharp maybe that's
kind of reminded me of like like brandon
turner's talking about bigger pockets
mobile home parts yeah
you could take one of those
and uh or develop something similar with
those airstreams but you know i
obviously we got to figure out here i
would i love the idea i would do that
yeah my sister has a gutted airstream
that still waiting to see what will
happen she's trying to sell it yeah
she's still um that she'll eventually do
something with it
but yeah because there are companies you
can just take it to and have them
renovated rather than because they're
tricky to do yourself because of like
the weight and everything like you have
to use a certain type of tile and
whatever um so that you can still haul
it
but i think that they're really cool
hopefully that'll be done if anyone is
watching this who's done this before or
knows how to do it reach out to info
what is it info at alexandria reach out
to info
alexandernava.com
or follow me
all right so
alex underscore nava underscore
photography seriously serious inquiries
only if you have one for sale message me
no no not if you have one for sale if
you could develop a community like that
of 100 airstreams oh i would i would
invest in that i would seriously i'd
fund it if someone else knows what what
they're doing and can run it i think i
know what i'm doing wow yeah no
seriously like this this is something i
would love and then i was thinking how
do you kick start it because you can't
just spend like you know 10 million
dollars creating this community and it's
like welp now we wait
kickstarter with youtube
wow i didn't know i didn't know you were
so intense invest in it no not mention
no no no but like marketing reviews yeah
yeah yeah right yeah because then you
you could fill it up pretty easily from
people who want to review it mm-hmm and
uh you know that helps gets the ratings
and you could boost up on airbnb yeah
and once you're at the top
you know
wow this is a foolproof role
yeah it is so if anyone's done this
before yeah or even like auto camp isn't
even probably on airbnb right like they
just like have their own website alex i
don't know are they um yeah we just got
we booked it directly through the
website so i they could be on airbnb i'm
not sure
but um the reason why graham was there
is also another reason they're making a
ton of money
and graham went and for a wedding oh
gosh yeah i mean they rented the whole
thing right
no no no no i mean out of 85 probably
the wedding reception was maybe like 15
of the units
oh wow
max but yeah but they host like weddings
there they had this like uh this grassy
area and they could yeah but like little
events and stuff like that but that's
extra cash right there too
yeah weddings like anything having to do
with weddings makes like three times
more than what you normally would yeah
like wedding videographers wedding like
dressages or whatever yeah mm-hmm i'm
gonna say
you have yeah kind of for fun but like
people have paid me and monica to
because it's it's sort of fun but it's a
very long day like every time after i do
it i'm like i'm never doing that again
yeah but it's fun the footage looks nice
it's fun to shoot like just a very
beautiful area because they're always
like made up really nice
so it's like satisfying like i always
love the footage
how many weddings have you done probably
like five has there ever been a couple
that you saw and you're like now that's
not gonna last
that's not where i thought that question
was going
who asked that grandpa i don't know
what do you think that's just not the
direction i thought the question was no
it's a great question
yeah yeah there's been a couple that
i've been like
i seem a little stressed for this day
but like i feel like i've gotten a lot
of insights on weddings because you're
like recording the people getting ready
and all of that
and people that have the bigger weddings
are always so much more stressed out
than the smaller ones they they seem
like they enjoy the day more
because it is just more of a production
when there's like 300 people there or
whatever i mean statistically three of
those are not going to make it yeah
you don't have to be so negative
immediately statistically yeah divorce
rates are over 50
no apparently apparently though it's
so it's less
if you're so the 50 is a broad range
includes second and third marriages
third and fourth so that skews it but if
you look at the first marriage
for people over a certain age with like
a college degree like like you start
whittling it down uh it's more like 25
28 yeah but you were whittling it down
yeah but if you look at like okay you're
not on your third marriage sure even
eliminating that what about just the
average joe
about one and three one and three yeah
thirty percent so
but the other thing though is that
which might skew it back up is that if
they look at millennials let's say they
just got married after like that's a
good point you know can you see that
through 30 years and say like okay what
about 35 years from now does that count
maybe just not enough time has passed
yeah i don't know yeah that's a good
point
they don't have enough data but yeah
let's yeah
we could just assume jack half we can
just throw that out there let's say a
half
i've had uh two cancellations uh that
were friends that have booked weddings
i have no clue how to handle that they
canceled on you yes they canceled
because they called off the wedding oh
wow and it was awkward because they're
like either friends or acquaintances
and so usually what i'll tell them is
i'll be like well you know i'd say like
you know give it a week or two you know
like i'll give you your money back but
like just i was like you know because
sometimes they get in fights and i've
seen it all the time brides and grooms
gets get invites before their their
wedding and then they're
they cancel but then they call you back
and they're like oh you know we we
figured it out we'd like to not cancel
so
it gets crazy out there i would be i'd
ask like what happened
i know okay so i'm so nosy the person no
no
yeah the person in me wants to ask but
the you know the the business in me is
like well that's none of my business
or acquaintances yeah just like a friend
of a friend yeah would just be i'm just
so curious like yo what happened let's
talk it through i'll give you my opinion
on it
that's another thing that i would love
to do so so we tried something new here
and we had people pitch us their
investments or or their like business
ideas i loved it we had um
read from uh
evan and reed came on
right
from yes
uh ketchup please yeah so i was about to
say ketchup that yeah so how old were
they 19 yeah
19 in college and they pitched us their
product called ketchup please which is a
really healthy ketchup and it was
delicious because it's like so smart so
ambitious it just it was really it's
really hard to grow in the condiment
because people don't like buy condiments
that often oh right um but i would love
to be like relationship advice yes same
but but fine but financial related so i
want to see a couple like just getting
into it over finances and uh and just
unsolicited advice like hey you want to
come on i'll help you out alex are you i
was going to say are you giving me
permission to to find people yes all
right so if you're watching this but you
got to weed them out alex you got to
make sure
there's actual trouble there all right
we don't want to be a jerry springer we
want text screenshots from before we
talked about this exactly of arguments
if you've had a financial argument and
you're in las vegas or don't mind
traveling here uh to be on the show
uh i'd be happy to talk to you and give
you my opinion what do you think about
that shelby i think it's interesting i
almost think of it as like a whole
separate show though
probably realistically it should not be
on the iced coffee hour but
we just we just throw you know our
standards
but is it harder to get guests not being
in la or there's still like a ton of
people always coming to vegas a ton of
people it's harder definitely like not
yeah it's harder not being in l.a
because
any influencer in l.a i feel like it's
i've noticed no difference
really really
i've noticed a little bit of a
difference between ellie and here i
wouldn't say it's particularly
challenging here still but i think it
was easier in l.a yeah i know just more
people were in a way
i think it's easier
everyone at some point comes to vegas
for something and they don't mind
traveling here
because there's something to do like la
it's like oh it's kind of expensive at
least vegas it's like oh it's a weekend
trip to vegas
totally yeah what brought you out here
um me and sam went to the it's like this
company view studios they opened a new
studio and had an event
and so he really wanted to go to it and
we're in
orange county area so we're like oh
let's go
we flew here for the weekend kind of
just for fun and to go to that and i was
like oh come on here
i was like when will i be able to do
that
so yeah just random trip nothing like
too crazy although i know nab is going
on
so that's why i view that company
they're basically like a virtual
production stage it's like really crazy
that they could shoot like movie or
commercial scenes on
so for that event pretty much yeah now i
think if you did van life
i tell this to just about everyone i
think you've told this to her before
have i have i told you this i think both
times we had her on every single day
i've been meaning to do a video doing it
for like a weekend
but i don't know if i'd do it like
forever
i would give it a week or two give it to
two weeks
try it out and i think
i think you could probably like triple
triple views by doing
van life yeah
yeah
everywhere you go you could pick
destinations to travel to and then make
a video not about that destination but
like weird things in that destiny like i
i like ryan treyhan did like the world's
largest potato i'm not saying you have
to do like the largest potato but like
every area is gonna have something
unique or like some bomb shelter like
just something you'd be able to do and
just strategically plan it out in
advance and just road trip around for a
week right like that yeah that would be
fun if you did that in a tesla model x i
think you because then you attract the
tesla crowd too yeah and you have one of
those like little mattresses in the back
of the car and like what that's like to
live in a tesla no i know i slept in one
once and i was like oh i never want to
do it again
because in the model x you know how the
um like the falcon doors make it so the
middle goes down kind of a lot and i
felt like weirdly claustrophobic in it
i actually felt like the model 3 was
felt a little bit roomier because it
just like arcs over you like that
so a week in a model x i'd be like oh my
gosh that's tough but a van that has
like the whole setup with like a mini
kitchen and a bathroom airstream
yeah an airstrip would be cool i think
if you did that or a luxury rv
try it yeah
wouldn't be hard
but driving it's a little like you have
to get a whole separate license for some
of those right no no i had a buddy who
rented one and just drove it i think if
it i think if it's under like 45 feet i
mean it's pretty generous in terms of
what you could do yeah okay
it's a good idea yeah i would do that
i'll try that over the summer yeah now
can we talk income
we don't have to talk too many specifics
but you've made the income breakdown
videos in the past sure you've not seen
an income breakdown video i know i
haven't made a reaction i haven't done
one in a while because my adsense
doesn't make as much i make more of
brand deals now
i don't know what it is maybe like after
covid there's just more
brands that are i think i see it
everywhere like almost every video i
watch on youtube has like a one minute
ad break do you find that yes yeah which
i'm like good for creators of course
because those are pretty easy to do yeah
um so i make more off of that than
ads but still like a solid amount like
i'll make like 10 thousand a month off
of ads on my main channel and then like
depending on how much i upload on my
vlog channel
two to eight
that's pretty good yeah yeah and now i
get uh yeah i get brand deals on my vlog
channel now too which i never expected i
was like what this is crazy that's
fantastic yeah
yeah i've noticed ad rates are down 20
to 30 percent sometimes a little bit
more but i think with the brand deals
not only are they more aggressive now
because um
like two years ago i was working with
these two companies and they would
they'd pitch brand deals and you know
every now and then but now they're just
like boom boom boom boom i've never
gotten so many offers yeah for
companies that in the past i never would
have imagined i mean legitimate
companies but now they're more
like mainstream companies are reaching
out um like i did one for a zip
recruiter and like that's a company like
what really zip recruiter okay great
yeah that's cool but they i felt i feel
like they never would have done that in
the past but then also youtube is
cracking down
really on that um
that doesn't include paid promotion
oh you have to check the box yes yeah so
no one was doing that before because in
the very beginning it would show like
this video includes paid promotion
and especially in finance you'd question
the entire video because like wait a
second does this mean the whole video is
like true you know it might be
financially biased towards one thing or
another
so they started cracking down and then
it made you have to you have to select
and obviously you're not gonna lie on
that so it's you know so now everyone
has to check is it paid or not if it is
and now people just are a little bit
more aware of it yeah now when i click
on a video i don't mind if it's has a
paid promotion i expect it oh yeah like
even if it doesn't say that because i
know like most big youtubers they're
gonna have like hello fresh in there or
something you know yeah it's never
bothered me and that's why sometimes i
don't get why why people would be upset
it's just like it's just like you watch
tv and it's commercial like no one would
ever be oh
my tv show is interrupted by a
commercial it's just like i think
youtube ads are worse than like in
sponsorships like because he could just
like tap the screen and skip past it but
if you have like an unskippable ad that
you know youtube provides it's like oh
you got to watch that youtube's got to
make their money too of course they do
of course somebody on reddit uh and i've
started seeing it every now and then
they've got three unskippable ads it's
like like they you know were they 15
seconds no yeah in a row it's like
they'll get like a five second one or
like a ten second a ten second
another five second or so like something
like it's still under 30 seconds but
it's still like and still when compared
to like you know television it's still
nothing you know television you have
like you know eight minutes of content
and then three minutes of commercials
yeah so much more yeah i think the
people that do get annoyed of
sponsorships i could see it if you're
not paying for the premium version of
youtube so if you like just watch
through an ad and then they do a
sponsorship and then there's like
another ad like that would be kind of
annoying but when you pay for like
premium youtube
it's really not i feel like i'm like oh
because i just never see ads on youtube
but i don't think that many people
actually pay for it you know what it is
it's those darn kids
what this it's the kids they're spoiled
yeah they don't know what it is
they don't know what it was like to
watch nickelodeon you get 14 minutes and
then you get like four minutes of
commercial and then like that's your
time to go make a big hot pocket yeah
the bathroom you gotta rush to get back
they don't know what it's like they
don't yeah and so when netflix is is
have you seen the netflix
maybe add ads to like a cheaper
subscription wait they are yeah yeah
because they're losing subscribers and
so they're like oh maybe we'll make like
a cheaper one with ads
no way yeah are they just losing it to
youtube just i think to the other
streaming platforms
to like hbo max has a lot of good shows
yeah that's true amazon
so people might be like oh yeah yeah
it's reverting back to cable it's weird
like we went from cable to netflix like
everything you need is on netflix and
now it's like you need netflix to disney
plus hulu like you mentioned yeah max
now there's four of them and so now
you're paying still less than cable but
you could be paying like 100 a month for
all the different streaming services to
get the shows that you want wow it's a
lot yeah but i still just watch youtube
the most same yeah but youtube is losing
people to tick-tock i know yeah i've
noticed even i go and tick-tock more now
do you post it on twitter used to a
little
not a lot i kind of want to more just
because it's like it's kind of fun but i
overthink every tick tock like i think
of it like a youtube video like it needs
to be good
but it doesn't really you can just make
it kind of quick
yeah the thing about tick tocks is you
can lack so much context and tick tocks
like you don't have to tell the full
story yeah like for example like if
we're clipping up one of graham's videos
you should really be condensing graham's
entire 14 minute video down into like 30
seconds and just remove all of the
context of everything and just have like
the facts and that's the only way that
you can be successful in tick tock
sometimes i don't want to though like
say i'm making a full youtube video
about like how much my airbnb made in
april i could make it a tick tock but
then i feel like no one's going to watch
the youtube different audience oh really
yes i am shocked okay totally fine yeah
your 3d printed home video would get
millions of views on tick tock and
that's the perfect idea
talk footage i'm gonna make one after
this do that all you need to do i
wouldn't even show your face just voice
over this is a 3d printed home it's it
just yeah make sure you add titles
though
that's very important like a lot of
people when they clip stuff up for tick
tock they make the entire thing like
captioned
do you guys have a goal with posting on
tick tock or just to like
brand awareness yeah like we realized
also like he said like the audiences
have nothing to do with one another for
example we posted a tick tock and it was
getting a hundred thousand views an hour
for probably 15 or 16 straight hours it
was probably one and a half million
views i noticed the difference in views
we were getting on youtube like that
were linked to that episode were about
20 per hour 20 views an hour on
something that was getting a hundred
thousand views an hour on tick tock it
there's no conversions from tick tock to
youtube it's pure brand awareness even
shorts i am shocked uh when we do shorts
the
the people that hit that video are
unlikely to watch like the long-form
content yeah the people who like shorts
like shorts the people who like the
long-form videos they like the long form
yeah yeah it's interesting we posted a
youtube short that it's at like 500 400
000 views the michael reeves one and 90
of the viewers were unique viewers so
people that had never seen the channel
before and still
disproportionately did provide us with
more subscribers than it would compared
to a normal podcast that we would post
with the same amount of views but still
like it it's just completely different
audience yeah they're not really going
to watch
like regular videos yeah um the other
thing i've noticed too is that some of
the tick tocks we posted do well on tik
tok don't do well on youtube yeah and
then others do well on youtube but not
tick tock i think it's kind of random on
that yeah i feel like tick tock is so
crazy how like you could get a million
views and then the next one could get
like five thousand like very few
it's wild that's why if i were a brand
that was like sponsoring someone i'd be
a little nervous about tick tock because
it'd be like is this going to be the one
that blows up they pay a lot less on
tick tock
a lot less yeah yeah it makes sense
because it's like a shorter video
although i've seen people make tons of
money through affiliates on tick tock
yeah and um when people release products
and they make tick tocks on it they can
make so much money just by selling a
product like that they can demo really
well yeah i worry what it's going to do
to people's like i don't see mental
health but yeah it's just like with your
attention rolling and scrolling and
scrolling and it i think that's where
we're going it's just like that quick
attention span of like hey if you don't
have 30 seconds then you're done i feel
like it's bad though like
maybe since tick-tock i don't know but
sometimes i'll even be like i feel like
i can't even brush my teeth without
looking at my phone or something i'm
like this is horrible yeah or like wait
in line for 10 seconds look at my phone
like yep it's so i'm i'm the same way
like this is oh so now when i was in
seattle recently
i was like strictly like i'm reading
before i go to sleep like i'm not
getting on my phone because i'll scroll
for like another hour
yeah we should expose ourselves right
now what what are your guys's screen
times
i like this let's do this
two phones you're gonna have to check
both of them i'll check the one with the
social media how do you know you have to
check both of them because we got to see
how much time you're spending on your
phone graham
i feel like that's a lot funny the
amount of people who send me two cents
on venmo
do they
just find it yeah i got one just now um
but i've gotten probably a few dozen of
them and everyone's like
two cents for uh i want to get your two
cents oh turn on screen you had it
turned on
i've never i've i've never
sure this is my phone i've never turned
it on no
it says see it wasn't tracking
daily average says an hour and 40
minutes or is that so far today no
that's your daily average
that's really good
yeah that's really good i i will say
i broke my phone working on my aquarium
um i had a bunch of water salt water
leaked onto it and i was without my
phone immediately after my phone broke
my first thought was how am i going to
get a new one as fast as possible yeah
that's how bad it was it's so bad my
phone was stolen last summer and i was
like so irritated
like the next day because i didn't have
it to do things i was like this is so
bad i'm like addicted to it that's why
you gotta get two phones
you see here
how do you use the two
the same he literally uses them for the
exact
a phone and then you could disable one
of the sims when you don't want to use
it like why are you carrying around two
phones if that's the only reason i'm
just used to it now you always text me
so like randomly on your other number
different names for each phone it
confuses me and then i get back to you
on the wrong number no i see them both
but sometimes it's because i'm on the
old phone and i'll be scrolling and i
just text you because i know you have
the number
so that's the thing you know that i'm
going to get back
wait so jack what was your screen time
uh it's bad man i'll show you mine i'll
show you mine five hours 40 minutes okay
no no that's not bad
broken up oh
oh you can't see that okay i don't know
five hours and five minutes is my daily
average this is up 41 from last week
though
oh so it's more than normal yeah like
it's usually what three hours then
mine's down 56 so mine's normally more
it's normally like three hours yeah they
were about the same yeah i just happened
to have a hefty week last week and also
like two and like half of it is messages
oh yeah which a lot of it is work
correspondence yeah that's surprising
because you never get back if you're
talking like distractions it's only 30
minutes on tick tock yeah that's not
that and 30 minutes is google maps
so it's like yeah it's not that i think
that's fine yeah but it's it's
concerning to me just how addictive i
think tiktok is yeah so many people and
just how quick time goes by when you're
on it yeah and they know what they're
doing it's the algorithm yeah it's crazy
yeah
so much content they could pick and
choose just like that that's the best
little bits and within 30 minutes it
knows you
and it knows by location too yeah so
when we traveled sure enough you're
getting yosemite tickets yeah instantly
things to do in las vegas yeah which i
kind of like i'm like right oh whoa i
want it i don't mind it yeah yeah i
wouldn't be surprised if it knows like
what you're doing on other apps too oh
i'm sure and it sees you text be like
i'm going to buy dog foods like show
dogs
i was working on a video
where you know how people do the like
buy stuff on alibaba and like make a
website for it and sell it i was like
working on a video where i try that so i
made a website and was like making a
tick tock ad for this product
and they were like you have to put on
your website if you're going to
advertise on tick tock this privacy
policy because they basically like
they make you
say like it's a copy and paste thing i
think from tiktok but it basically just
is because tick tock is looking at more
stuff i think is what it is wow and so
you have to like disclose that or they
won't even like show your ad that's
crazy that would be another great video
for you to do is to get a brand new
phone brand new like like not traced to
you just like with a burner sim card or
whatever and see if your phone listens
to you into what degree
oh yeah be like i'm gonna travel to a
new location let's just see what happens
and you know i'm gonna say these words
here okay now i'm gonna send a few texts
and like keep going down the rabbit hole
until pretty soon it knows like where
you are what you like what you're doing
how old you are like
i think that would be pretty cool yeah
all the ads yes
see just like just how well it gets in
yeah that would be interesting
yeah maybe i'll try that yeah you know
what i i gotta i gotta run really quick
jack do you mind taking it over i got
something really important yeah yeah go
for it there's a like button that needs
to be hit yeah what'll this be like a
minute or two something like that all
right
i'll be right back all right yeah so you
guys may notice something looks a little
off here
yes uh graham uh what did you do he got
a hair got a haircut yeah so he looks
like this now no i'm just kidding guys
this is alex graham's actually on a
flight here and uh we're in a bit of a
time crunch because shelby our guest
right here she has to leave uh where are
you going i'm going to maui and the
flight's at 5 40 so we're like trying to
make it work yeah your flight leaves in
like an hour or so and graham's flying
into vegas so he's a bit late to the
podcast due to uh some flight delays so
we're just recording this before graham
arrives but we'll throw it in on the
second half of the podcast yeah we'll
still make it work we will make it work
so thanks for making all this happen
yeah thanks for having me again i was
excited to come back the one thing i do
want to talk about i i have a question
uh and i'm gonna look so stupid if if
shelby's not the one who did this
probably not i'm sorry shall we did you
do the rent out your pool was that you
oh i did a video where i tried it yeah
yeah yeah okay
yeah so before you did that i've been
telling graham that he should let me his
assistant rent out his pool and let me
make some income yeah people make a lot
on it like i rented one
i rented two for that video i think
maybe one more i can't remember but i
rented one and i talked to the host
because i was like explaining how i was
making a video about it he was like yeah
it pays like quite a bit i forget
exactly how much he said but a lot of
them are like a hundred dollars an hour
and
but the thing is it's pretty expensive
to heat a pool oh so it has to be for
that yeah people want it heated
but i guess it's like if it's already
like pretty hot out it's not as
expensive to heat a pool like if it's 90
degrees every day it's really not as
much so it could be worth it i mean if
people are renting it every day then it
could be
i forget though how much it seemed worth
it if so many people are on the platform
that's pretty crazy a hundred dollars an
hour yeah
that's insane what are the types of
people that rent these books because i
could never imagine myself going i'm
like i'm gonna rent the pool for four
years imagine you get together with your
friends and you want like a private pool
that you can it's not it's in someone's
backyard no yeah but at least it's not
like you know you're not at a hotel with
like a bunch of randoms you know
you're renting the pool so i think those
are the types of people but
i think that you should try it out jack
because jack's been experimenting with
renting out a room in his bedroom on
airbnb we do have a pool too i do you
should rent it out and see and make a
video yeah
so i rented out my room i was planning
on talking about this when graham was
here but he already knows all the
stories yeah so you're in the airbnb
game
i tried it and i had five people like
five nights three people five nights it
was fine i was really surprised at how
easy it was to get on airbnb right like
i don't know if the qualifications are
different if it's a separate house
versus if it's a room because i was just
doing a room but it was very easy all
right guys i'm gonna go pick up grandpa
okay yeah yeah this is all the time i
got guys thanks alex thank you guys
appreciate you know i will be picking up
graham you guys continue the
conversation and i will be right back
thanks alex
a lot of people are worried with swimply
like the liability of course like what
if somebody drowns in your pool i'm
worried about airbnb in the liability
yeah it definitely i have insurance for
that just liability insurance you have
to in the city of palm springs they make
you
so there's a lot more rules in palm
springs than probably here or most
places really so actually setting up the
airbnb listing is so easy and simple
but
if you are somewhere that has like the
city has regulations then your listing
is illegal but i bet here there aren't
really any yeah
okay so actually technically airbnb
isn't even legal in las vegas oh really
i think it's going to be passed and it
will be made legal in like a couple
months but they're also not because
the entire economy in las vegas revolves
around like hotels and like visitors so
they probably are trying to lobby yeah
absolutely so airbnb is going to be
legal in a couple of months but when
they do make it legal i heard what what
it's going what's going to happen is uh
you're only going to be able to have
five listings
that's kind of a lot it is a lot but i
was also wondering it's like if you're
doing rooms then five rooms isn't that
much but i heard it was just five
listings in total so whether that be a
room whether that be like a guest unit
or a full house it's like you can only
have five which is also like not super
motivating if i was planning on getting
into the airbnb game knowing that like
i'm capped at five yeah i mean you could
always get one or two here and then
get some in other places yeah true i
kind of like that idea because then you
could have a like a mountain yeah your
own place to stay as well yeah yeah i
like the idea of that like having i mean
i think it would be really cool to have
five different airbnbs like one where
you can go skiing one near a beach
the desert one
it's hard to get them in major cities
though because that's where you run into
all the rules
yeah and i actually like that idea a lot
right it'd be cool because then you get
travel for free yeah i found i actually
spend a lot less money too
on like a vacation because i just go to
palm springs out and the house is free
essentially
for me
so
that's kind of a nice perk to it it's
like if you already own a bunch of
airbnbs you're not really gonna care as
much
to go travel somewhere else like you
probably will a little bit but it you
don't like have that craving as much see
that sounds lovely when i was renting
out a room in my house i was like having
random people come and stay with me yeah
i wasn't a huge fan i i really i got to
be honest i hated it yeah like people
coming and staying that was fine and
then people were really nice and
amicable and we got along just fine
but
the second people that stayed uh like
they requested early check-in and late
check out and i granted it to them you
know but like at the same time i was
like okay this is not a good sign and
then between the time of checkout and
late check out the extra hour or two
that i gave them
this girl brought over her ex-boyfriend
and he smoked a cigarette in my room oh
what and i was in your room
yeah that's still weird though yeah i
know and it was in between the like
extra time that i gave them it was in
that hour so i was like oh my gosh and
then after that i was like okay i don't
want to rent to anyone else and i was i
tried to turn off instant book
apparently i didn't and i got instant
booked like the next day oh yeah and
then that person recognized me and that
made me kind of the whole situation a
little unique you know what i mean
because obviously you have to watch what
you say and do like around anybody uh if
they're you know just like i don't know
staying at your house but especially if
they know who you are then you're like
okay i really have to like you know my
best behavior yeah oh my gosh yeah i
would be nervous to rent out just a room
yeah i had an old roommate who said that
she did that when she was in college and
it paid for her whole rent like she did
it when one of her roommates moved out
early and then she just rented a room
and most of people were
fine but it was on rare occasion you get
someone that's just like crazy yeah i
think
that's true like i haven't had any
terrible airbnb guests but there was one
kind of difficult one
and i feel like that's just sort of
bound to happen
and so it's way more invasive if it's
like your own house
like for the palm springs house if
something breaks in it i'm kind of like
detached like it's fine we'll just get
something out you have a property
manager and everything yeah yeah and it
feels like
a business like it doesn't feel like my
personal stuff like if something really
bad happens to it i'd just be like well
it's fine we'll just get another
so
i want to talk about the airbnb stuff
more but i'm like i'm just thinking like
graham who wants some of the
conversation i know yeah that's like
i'll ask you random
uh
random questions okay okay cool who are
your biggest mentors in your life like
the people that you idolized and what
were your biggest takeaways from them
hmm this is a tough one because i feel
like i haven't had a lot of like
uh traditional like oh that's my mentor
or whatever i guess maybe with you could
say idols people that yes you learned a
lot from it could even be like a random
youtuber that taught you a lot i'll
always have a few channels where i'm
like whoa i really like their editing or
like so that's a lot of what you take
away when you consume youtube is like
the style of production yeah or even
just like the fonts people use whatever
and um have you seen johnny harris's
videos they're so good the editing it's
like he was a journalist for vox and so
they're just very professional
and i feel like i've
accidentally stumbled into like almost
making like journalistic style videos
like documentaries yeah yeah so i saw
his and i just thought it was really
cool that he's like an actual journalist
youtuber because there will haven't
really been much of that it's like
people making videos but they wouldn't
be considered actual journalists and i
think that he actually is
like you would consider him one so his
videos are really cool
um i'm trying to think i mean when i was
it doesn't have to be youtube related
yeah yeah i guess just like
coaches that i had doing gymnastics and
stuff growing up
my brother also have an older brother
and he's always had just a very strong
work ethic that inspired me to work
harder probably than if i didn't have a
brother like i feel like he'd be very
much like
get good grades and my parents are kind
of chill about it like they're like you
know it's fine but my brother would be
like you should really like try in
school you should try yeah give it a
good effort yeah
so
yeah i would say that
um
i'm trying to think or even i went to
orange coast college when i first moved
to california and the teachers there
were very
like
i guess
they were they just like were very
helpful because the classes are really
small it's a community college
and they could have easily been sort of
i don't know go the traditional film
route like
transferred to
chapman or usc or one of those film
schools but they were like what you're
doing is great like really
were pushing for youtube because they
were seeing the future of it back in
like 2014 when a lot of people thought
what is this still like is this really a
job
and so that was really helpful because
they taught me a lot about how to
actually shoot better and edit better
and all of that
and we're just really
encouraging rather than being like
this stuff isn't good like they i don't
know i thought going into it they would
think youtube was kind of silly and like
not that good but they were like
the biggest hype people that's crazy
especially back in 2014 like you said
when like everyone there was a huge
stigma on youtube and i mean there still
is it's like oh you can make money off
of that that's what everyone says but at
the same time it's like especially back
then right and i don't know i just
thought it would seem like embarrassing
to like a more legit like film thing but
they were all about it so that was
really cool
and like some of them were like oh
i remember one teacher connected me to
someone to try and get a job at like cbs
or something like that it was cbs yeah
but obviously i just do youtube so that
has worked out i've never done like a
regular job
never never you've never like worked at
a restaurant you've never
i really retailed when i was younger i
really wanted to work at starbucks like
up the street
but your parents didn't let you or what
oh i was 14 so you couldn't yeah that
makes sense and i just started making
videos then so by the time i was the age
where you could get a normal job
it would have been like a pay cut from
youtube like it would have been like
that's crazy right do you feel like
there's a part of you that's like
missing since you never got to
experience like kind of like 95 or
something like that yeah and a lot of
people are like trust me you don't want
to but i kind of wish i knew for myself
yeah i thought about just a life
experience at the end of the day yeah
totally and i i like having structure
and all of that like i kind of liked
being in school when i was in school
like i wasn't one of those people who
really hated it
but i i do prefer
kind of just doing my own thing i think
there is like a reason a lot of
nine-to-five jobs are the way that they
are because it kind of works
right you know how a lot of people want
to work for themselves so that they
don't have to work as much or can work
weird hours but then you find when you
do work for yourself you probably work
more or
you stick to nine to five hours anyway
like i kind of stick to that because if
you don't you're still going to get
emails or whatever it is when you're not
working or whatever
so it just gets like confusing if you
don't stick to it i think
it's just so silly it's like when i was
working at like an actual job like i was
a bus boy at a restaurant it's like i
would do anything to be like an
entrepreneur working my own schedule
like you know doing whatever i want with
all my free time but now it's like you
know i've been doing it for like two
three years now and now i'm just like oh
my gosh like i just want like a
structure like nine to five even like
that sounds amazing right now as silly
as that seems like clocking in and
clocking out yes sometimes it does seem
nice to be able to go somewhere and then
just
do you want what you can't done with it
yeah that's exactly what it is yeah so i
don't know people are probably watching
and they're like shut up like youtube i
know i i probably sound so ridiculous
saying that but it's just so hard to
stay structured
like for example like five comes around
a big part of it is like
knowing how to turn off the work brain
and it's like five comes around and it's
like things always come up after five
and it's like you know seven you say you
want a hard deadline at seven stuff
comes around at eight grand will text me
at nine hey what do you think about this
thumbnail and then i spend you know some
time thinking about the thumbnail or
whatever yeah little things like that
yeah i always try to like when the sun
is down i really don't want to work on
anything
because i feel like yeah so like in the
winter it's a little earlier
but it's like actually just the way that
i work i find i'm not even like my brain
is not fresh anymore i'm not even doing
a good job at things once i'm kind of
tired like i'm very much a morning
person so i'd rather wake up early and
get everything done and then have the
afternoon to chill or work out or
whatever that makes sense how's your
like work life balance right now how
many hours do you work per week what's
your teamwork
lately it's my work life balance has
been a lot more life than work
yeah because basically i've been like
sort of a nomad like i put all my stuff
in storage and then i've done a couple
month-long airbnbs and whenever i do
that i'm able to like get in a routine
and work on a lot of videos
but this last week has been more of just
like bouncing around so i get a good
amount of editing done but anytime you
have to go to the airport and like do
all that you end up wasting so many
hours just like in the car yeah yeah
walking through the airport
and it's kind of exhausting too like
once you get there i always want to like
rest a little bit
so
i haven't been working as much but i
have so much stuff still to edit and i
feel like i've still had the same output
somehow
um but i actually just signed a lease
for an apartment and so i think once i
get back into a routine it'll be much
more
structured so i really don't even know
how many hours i would consider
i've worked honestly but not as probably
half as much as i usually do in the last
month
just from like traveling around but yeah
but you're still maintaining yeah that's
the thing that i've realized is it's
like it's very easy to maintain and it's
very easy just to like keep whatever you
have been doing going forever and like
you can do let's say 90
of what you usually do with like you
know 30 of the time allocation yeah it's
just like it's so there's so much time
that's wasted it's like parkinson's law
kind of it's like
the job will take as long as the amount
of time that you give to do the job yeah
i know i thought a lot about that
because i do go the extra mile when i
have more time or when i'm in a routine
but also sometimes it just doesn't
matter that much going the extra mile
can take like you know 200 of the amount
of time you wanted to yeah it to take
and then all of a sudden it's like is it
really worth it yeah
i know i've thought about that because
it'll be like for one
shot yeah and if you have to drive 20
minutes to go get it and whatever yeah
so i used to do that a lot more but
lately i've been like okay i can
repurpose an old shot like doesn't
really matter
um
yeah do that kind of thing
but you have your own youtube channel
now right hardly yeah yeah
i mean i have i have two videos posted i
have two videos in the works right now
there's been this one video that was a
complete monster to edit it was like
seven hours of rough nearly eight
actually hours of raw footage so i
walked to st george utah for a tinder
date
oh my god yeah and i walked straight
into the tinder date after like you know
yeah i mean that's like a mr beast type
of title i feel like yeah i feel like
you know it's kind of an exciting thing
but it's it's so hard to edit that style
of video when i'm so used to like
editing other types of videos such as
reaction videos and like yeah random
stuff like that it's just it's very
technical i'm not a great technical
editor but i'm good at keeping rhythm
and keeping pacing and stuff like that
but like
it's always nice to have a video where
you know
all you really have to do is cut out the
dead space and add some music and titles
yeah like those are sort of fun to edit
whenever i edit my main channel videos
i'm like oh my god it's like doing a
puzzle yeah so i'm like okay where
should i put this i end up changing
everything so sometimes it's like i'd
rather just edit a vlog because they're
so easy like those are actually really
fun to edit yeah but main channel stuff
unless i just shot footage that i'm like
so excited to use because it turned out
really good yeah then i can be a little
bit like daunted with that
yeah i feel that this entire project has
been so daunting like i filmed it like
nearly two months ago and i've just been
sitting on it and i've edited like a
decent amount of it like we brought down
the eight hours to 40 minutes or 35
minutes but at the same time it's just
like oh my every time i open up the
timeline i just look at him just like
this is going to be like six hours and
i'll get a minute no you know that's i
mean that's how i felt with that i
showed you guys that only fantasy
documentary yeah and i still haven't
posted that because it's the same thing
so much footage
that's the thing i i'm asking myself the
same question so it's not like you know
what i mean i know i mean i have a cut
that's pretty much done but i need to
like go add little things but every time
i go to open it it takes like
literally 20 minutes to even open the
file oh just to render it yeah because
it'll have missing clips so i have to
re-link everything and that whole
process takes a while so it's not
something i'm gonna like real quick like
open my laptop and get a little bit of
editing done yeah it's like you know
you're gonna need like a four hour block
to work on this
and then with like every i've just found
this year there's been so many like
brand stuff like things that just come
up and i end up not prioritizing it when
i don't know i really want to get it out
there but yeah yeah that's been the
exact same story with me and the the
tinder video it's just so much
yeah it's hard because you still i mean
you work on the podcast
do you still work with graham yeah it's
i mean pretty much like i will say
a lot of my responsibility is the
podcast and then i hired out a lot of
the stuff that i was doing so graham
still like sources his work or like the
you know the production of certain
channels through me but then i just
source that through someone else and i
kind of like him quality control making
sure that like the standards are still
hit the deadlines are still hit and it's
actually i found it more profitable for
us i mean graham's costs have stayed the
exact same i have like so much more time
on my hands and i'm able to allocate you
know to other things where it's like i'm
not editing let's say where like maybe
my my time value is like you know a wage
like 30 bucks an hour 40 bucks an hour
or something like that and i can go do
something that you know find another
sponsor or try to scale on tick tock or
something like that yeah what do you do
with now the more free time
honestly play ping pong i play a lot of
ping pong yeah it's it's bad fun yeah
it's fun i love it i'm having a great
time i'm just critiqued by graham a lot
okay i'm very pro having hobbies i feel
like people don't have as many
hobbies because everyone's like working
all the time yeah but now that i've
found i can
even like
i feel like i could work like very few
hours in a week and it'd be fine but
then i do like get excited about a video
and i want to more yeah but it's just
not that fulfilling if you are
constantly working and you just like
have nothing else like i feel like you
end up getting bored of whatever you get
better at working when you work less
yeah it's like if you work less i found
a positive roi on that as silly as it
may seem but like the time that i do now
spend working it's like i'm getting done
like five times as much work as i was in
an hour now than i was back in the day
when i was doing all that stuff
so and and this is like a big qualm or
gripe that graham and i have with each
other it's like graham's like yeah you
gotta work more and it's like i've been
in the trenches and i've i've done the
thing where like you work like
ridiculous amount of hours every week
for you know a year too straight and i
hated it and i wasn't getting that much
done and it's a personality type that
can do it that can like work all the
time and like they really do actually
love it but i feel like that's not
everyone it's not a lot of people
probably
but like i still feel guilty if i'm not
working like yeah me too a lot
just because it's kind of how our
society is i like working
all the time but
yeah i don't know i feel like it can be
helpful to not a little there's a lot of
pressure to just work a lot and i'm not
like anti-work at all like at all i love
working but especially being in this
environment when you're around like
people that are like i'm building this
new vertical i'm coming out with my own
chocolate bar and stuff like that and
it's like oh my god like everyone's
doing so much and then you look at
yourself and you're like well i have
another podcast episode of two more
sponsors and you're just doing the same
thing and you're maintaining it's kind
of like it's disheartening you know i
try to keep the perspective that like
you know working right now and gaining
money and wealth or whatever it's like
that's all it means to an end so it's
like you have to remember that like are
you working to get more money to have
more free time you know what i mean it's
like what if you can have a good balance
right now what if you can enjoy your you
know your money right now or your free
time right now so right i know i think a
lot
i feel like a lot of people can but
don't let themselves certainly sometimes
for good reason to like maybe you're
really working to like set up
yourself later
but there are people who like they have
more than enough for the rest of their
life even and they're still just working
like so much some people just they just
like working you know some people like
entrepreneurship and stuff like that i
love entrepreneurship and i like working
a lot but i like working when i feel
like the time that i am spending working
is like actually doing something and i
don't want to add more work on when i
feel like it's just redundant work or
it's work that isn't important i want to
try to find something first that i feel
like okay i have an impact with this
work and then i can go head first into
that right but i'm not going to try to
force it and just work to
no reason just doing it for the sake of
staying busy
yeah i've totally done that before just
been like i should be doing something
productive right now like and then you
don't do anything productive yeah it's
just like kind of i don't know it would
be more productive to sit and to think
and just to go for a walk and enjoy your
time yeah like you know actually going
for walks
i come up with the like i think a lot of
good ideas doing that but it's easy to
forget to because like
in a lot of cities you don't you have to
like intentionally go walk like i think
the only maybe i'm sure there's more but
like if you're in new york you're
walking all the time
and i feel like it gives you more energy
and i think more ideas i just kind of
enjoy it like that's something i've
realized yeah i love walking that was i
mean that was a huge portion of like the
whole walking to utah thing because like
you already like it i love walking yeah
and i thought oh well i can combine
walking and film a video about it and it
has to be clickable so i'll walk into a
tinder date i'm like well it all works
out but i'm with you on that and there's
also a study that was done that shows
that forward momentum that you create
when you're walking it creates like
forward thinking it's weird so like if
you're moving forward then your brain
can think in some more effective way or
something like that there were studies
that were done on that so that's what
graham and i used to do when we lived in
santa monica together we would go for
walks every single day and we would be
thinking about like video ideas topics
like how we can grow and scale the
business and stuff like that while we
were walking because it was more
effective that way i know i've heard of
i forget who it is but different like
successful people that do walking
meetings
only walking meetings yeah it's like
instead of meeting for coffee like
they'll go on a walk with someone that's
like the meeting yeah because i feel
like it kind of gets her brain thinking
differently
how does it make you feel
when you see another video titled
millionaire reacts shelby church
something something something money
um because we've done like at this point
10 of them maybe oh really okay
i've seen some where i'm like wait that
video wasn't even new like you guys must
have found it and you're like oh we
should react to this yeah and i'm like
that one's so old
um okay i used to get i mean the first
time i ever saw one i was like
what the heck like what what did he say
you know like i thought weird
now you're just used to it and then yeah
but watching it he never says anything
like that mean yeah what does he say
that is mean though i don't remember
because i haven't watched him in a long
time i should react to his reaction or
whatever i think i was i i recorded that
a long time ago but i never uploaded it
um
i think sometimes
the thumbnails are out of hand i think i
told them that once i was like they're
they actually crack me up i'm like how
do you guys even think of this like his
head exploding
um but sometimes it's like well really
clickbaity but it does work yeah
see that's the thing graham likes to
take a positive situation and in the the
packaging of the video spin it in a bad
way which like it works unfortunately
that's what gets the clips click on like
fear stuff yeah well that's because it's
a very easy emotion to trigger yeah it's
like one of the reasons why i feel like
shane dawson's whole like docu-series
did well is because like they were all
rooted in like being scary and like it's
such an easy emotion to elicit and for
an audience for creator one of the most
powerful things you can do is to get the
viewer feel some sort of like actual
notion whether that be like rage even
towards yourself to the creator rage or
sadness or fear and it's just like yeah
yeah i mean his thumbnails do get me
because i'm like wait like
the housing market is gonna burst yeah
and then you click on it it's like the
housing market's doing super well guys
make sure you dollar cost average in
yeah yeah
yeah it's not like total click bait
where you click on the video and it's
about something totally different or
like sometimes you know
yeah we really try to border that you
know i feel like people still get
something out of it though yeah if they
are interested in personal finance
yeah it's not like yeah i think it would
be totally different if the club is just
like pushing like sketchy tactics that's
exactly my logic behind it too it's like
well if you have to clickbait it's fine
because we're teaching people good
things i think so too i think it's like
a net positive yeah what you're doing
yeah
yeah
well yeah
does he run out of video ideas or like
all the time okay yeah yeah like like
literally to the point of being like all
right jack i have no idea what to talk
about there's nothing going on in the
markets i've checked every single
website i've looked at reddit cnn like
everything no i can't find anything and
i'm like well let's just think and then
we just think sometimes not too much as
you know as much as we used to when we
lived together but like yeah we would
just think like well can you make a
video about this i've already done that
four times all right let's go to the
next one you come up yeah yeah it's hard
to just be like okay i'm just gonna
think of ideas
i feel like i come up with like
10 bad ones and then maybe one good one
where i'm like okay
maybe work
that's what mr beast does he has like oh
he just like sits and forces himself so
i think i heard somewhere i don't
remember exactly where it was from but
like people would provide uh mr beast
with like a list of maybe let's just say
you know maybe i'm not i'm not getting
the numbers right but like a hundred or
so video ideas and he just goes through
every single one of them and then
circles like five of them and then from
those five they weed it down to like you
know one or two wow
i actually did a video where i
hired someone on fiverr to like write
the video idea for me and i hired a few
different people so i hired one person
to come up with video ideas for me and
it was really interesting to see what
they came up with and they would have
reasons for it they're like this is
pretty searchable but it was really
random stuff like how to make a campfire
like things that were just like wait i
don't think that would fit on my channel
yeah but it it's helpful i think to have
someone have a fresh set of eyes and
look at it
me and my friend were talking about how
we want to do like a creator retreat
like everyone goes and stays at a cool
airbnb or something
and
we're assigned to think of like five
video ideas for each person's channel
and then present them one night so
everyone can hopefully come away with
some cool ideas that would be awesome
right it would be i think it would be
helpful and like productive yeah
that would be fantastic yeah something
like that
but i hate organizing that stuff yeah
that's always the worst yeah do you
strictly budget
no
not at all i mean i probably should but
i really
don't
because i just i don't know i spend
definitely less like much less than i'm
making
but i don't really budget it out like
that crazy
i'm a firm believer in like budgets are
generally good for people but at the
same time it's like the best budget that
you can potentially have is just to not
have expensive taste so it's like i
don't budget for myself because i know
that like i i know that sounds so
ridiculous i got this for free this one
right here it looks like an expensive
shirt i got it for free the watch was an
investment but i don't have expensive
taste so it's really easy for me to like
not have a budget and not be in a whole
me too like i've always been more of a
saver than a spender yeah and so i trust
that i'm never really like
going over that because i'm i'll still
be like weirdly cheap about things that
where it doesn't even make sense
sometimes
like adding avocado to something i won't
do it either yeah sometimes i won't but
a lot of times i will but like it's like
a two dollar add-on and then i won't
blink about like hiring someone to get
like footage for 300 or whatever yeah
but it's different it's hard to budget
too when
you're making videos
and you have all these business expenses
like
i don't know sometimes i'll be shooting
and i'll buy lunch for whoever's helping
me shoot but i feel like that's just
reasonable thing to do yeah
so yeah that whole avocado thing is so
funny because i was out i was out at uh
it was actually during the walk where we
swung by a a subway it was me and
my brand manager
and uh and i didn't add avocado and he
was like jack why didn't you have
avocado like i know you like it and i
said well you know an extra dollar and
he's like why'd you get the sandwich
that you got and i was like this is the
cheapest in which on the like the menu
yeah and like it's so silly because like
for two dollars extra i could have got
avocado or maybe i could have got a
better sandwich but it's like
those expenses are the hardest ones but
like other random stuff i i totally
agree with you it's like
i don't know the stuff for the house
it's like i'll spend you know
a grand on random stuff like i just
spent a thousand dollars for speakers
for my car yeah it's like it's so like
it it doesn't work you know
i don't know why those tiny expenses are
so challenging i know but then yeah i
know i feel the same thing like i spent
so much on the palm springs airbnb
that it almost made me feel like oh it's
okay to spend this much i'm like wait no
no this is like yeah for something yeah
and it will pay off but
yeah it's
i i don't know i feel like
budgeting is yeah obviously good if you
need to but it's kind of like
i don't i just i'm like
i don't like it i don't want to like
live my life that way so it takes a lot
of time yeah yeah and it just makes it
not fun so what do you spend your money
on is it mostly experiences or is it
material things
lately it's just a lot of travel like a
lot of airbnbs airplane tickets like
going out to dinner that kind of thing i
like never buy clothes
because i can't i'm like living out of a
suitcase the last six months so like
occasionally i will but
i just it makes me not want to buy
clothes because i don't want to have to
deal with them like i just only have so
much space
which i think is kind of a good thing um
but i definitely spend a lot of money
just on things for videos or like a lens
like i recently bought a lens that was
like a thousand dollars and that was a
thing where
i just was like oh i need this like i i
didn't even think twice about it yeah
obviously way more expensive than like a
two dollar add-on avocado yeah but
because it's for a video it feels just
justified um
so yeah i feel like it's a lot
on travel more on experiences yeah
or like setting up the airbnb that was
definitely like what i spent the most
money on so furniture stuff like that
which was kind of a fun way
to
like satisfy wanting to buy material
things yeah justifying it by a business
yeah like it still was fun and it felt
like i guess yeah it's still technically
like my stuff
but it made it so i didn't you don't
have the attachment to it yeah yeah so
i feel like putting all my stuff in
storage made me have like a lot less
attachments to things in general
because i thought i would even like miss
having my own bed but once it's like in
storage i didn't even think about it i
was like oh i'm actually better sleeping
all
all over the place than i was before
so why are i'm confused so you're just
traveling all over the place you don't
have it like a technically like a
residence basically
i well now i do i like have an apartment
in seattle but i have to go set it up
when i get back from this next trip
because i'm because i'm kind of sick of
it honestly but
i my
like lease was up in la and i was
looking at other places and they just
didn't even feel worth it like it was
when
all the rents were going up
probably like 20 from what they were the
previous year because all the kova deals
they like want to make their money back
from that
so i would tour these places and be like
i just am not excited to pay
three thousand dollars a month for this
like it just doesn't even feel worth it
and i had been in la for like eight
years
but i didn't really know where i wanted
to go so i like was able to get
um like a storage company to let me
store my stuff for free for four months
so i was like why not try this just
putting it in a video
oh um so yeah i was like why not try it
one of my friends was gonna be in new
york for a month anyway i'll start there
and go for the month and it was really
fun like i really wanted to move to new
york after that but then touring places
in new york i was like this is like it
feels like a scam oh is it that
expensive yeah like the amount you pay i
just posted a video touring some places
so these were like prime locations this
broker showed me so you can find a nice
place in like brooklyn or like the
financial district places that are maybe
a little less inconvenient but still
pretty cool yeah yeah um but he showed
me like the prime location so of course
they're gonna be like way more expensive
and it was like five thousand dollars a
month
no washer and dryer in the unit like
they weren't even really that
nice like the inside wasn't that nice
either no like it was fine it was still
like kind of nice but not compared to
what you can get literally anywhere else
and that's like a mortgage of like a
million dollar house when you think
about it like that you're like this is
crazy and then also in new york you pay
way more in taxes right and so that
together i was like
whoa why do people do this yeah like i
get it it's like a really
amazing city but when you really look at
like exactly how much you're paying
to live there
it's crazy i'm like i don't know i'd
rather just visit i guess so you landed
on seattle yeah why seattle because i'm
from there and i haven't lived there
since i like
moved eight years ago i've never really
lived in the city i lived in a suburb
when i grew up there
um
and so i think it'll be cool it's way
cheaper there's no state income tax
there
um i found an apartment that i actually
am excited about and that's like nice so
that was part of it is just being like
okay this is a place i actually want and
i feel worth paying for
than
everywhere else but i feel like i'm
gonna miss
the good weather of california so i'm
like i don't know i'll try seattle maybe
it'll be fine because i can go to palm
springs from time to time but like
yeah just try it out for a little bit
right my brother lives in seattle he
likes it oh yeah and idubbbz is moving
to seattle oh really yeah cool it's
very nice in the summer so it's like
going into the summer will be awesome
but i think the winter might be like
okay i don't know yeah i don't know
about this yeah it's very gloomy yeah
and that wraps up jack chat thank you
guys so much for tuning in thank you
shelby for being my first ever guest to
jack chat and youtube yeah get your free
stock down below in the description
using graham's affiliate link sign up
for the mentorship group shelby shout
out what you want to shout out tell
people uh what's up um you can go check
out my main channel shelby church
if you've never seen it go check it out
so thank you so much for coming on
shelby it's great seeing you it's the
third time you've been on the podcast we
appreciate it yeah i also appreciate you
getting your free stock down below in
the description in the up for pubg using
the code grant because that's worth all
the way up to a thousand dollars yes the
fastest
yeah yeah that's good awesome thank you